Got Complicated lecture,
they,
I to talk about nationalism.
Um,
and I do so with a skepticism that of course you'll,
uh,
you'll quickly pick up on,
aggressive nationalism,
help,
uh,
unleash the demons of the,
of the 20th century I beginning with where we're one,
which,
which unleashed even more dangerous demons,
uh,
after that.
Uh,
so I want to talk about,
um,
about nationalism and particularly I in,
in a little bit in France,
but,
but I in places that one does it usually consider all ended up drawing on my,
a friend Tim Snyder's work to talk a little bit about,
about Lithuania and Belarus and why they,
they're nationalisms.
Uh,
we're,
we're very,
very different in the,
in the,
in the second case,
uh,
I didn't really exist at all,
in the 19th century.
Uh,
and I'm going to,
um,
give a counter example,
which of course is which I treat in the book,
but of course it's the Austrian Hungarian Empire.
Uh,
and,
and it's funny because one couldn't have imagined,
uh,
in the 1970s looking installs quickly back on the Austria Hungarian Empire,
this polyglot,
uh,
a Habsburg,
um,
uh,
regime,
but the horrors of the Balkans,
I really made lots of historians and other social scientists look back,
uh,
and try to figure out how it was that,
instead of asking why it was the Australian and Gary and empire collapsed during
World War One are really at the end of World War One.
A turning the question around and saying,
how did it hold together so long?
So the [inaudible] Gary and empire is sort of a counterexample to,
uh,
to these nationalisms.
And of course,
one of the things that,
that,
uh,
brought the empire down along with,
with the war was a competing national claims from ethnic minorities,
uh,
within,
within that,
those fast domains.
But I want to start with,
with,
with a story.
It's something that I,
it's a book I read,
uh,
um,
all it maybe five or six years ago and the histories have their history.
So I'm going to tell,
uh,
the history of this particular book and you'll see kind of what I'm getting at.
And,
and the book,
by the way,
I sent out whenever you had a great idea,
emailed me saying,
why don't you send out the,
the terms before the lecture.
So actually that was a great idea.
I'd never thought of that.
And I did it last night,
a though I didn't put this particular book on it.
Um,
anyway,
the book is a Anastasia Caracas see,
do have fields of wheat hills of blood passages to nationhood in Greek,
Macedonia 1870,
1990.
And when I say that history's have their own history,
what I mean is the following in this book,
uh,
this anthropologist a who is from both Turkish and Greek extraction on either
side of her family is writing a book about a,
a small part of Macedonia in Macedonia of course,
was heavily contested centuries.
Uh,
it was,
uh,
you know,
in the middle of a trade route went through it,
uh,
in Macedonia,
there were,
were Turks and the,
and there were Serbs and they were Bulgarians and Macedonians and Greeks.
And for centuries they'd all basically gotten along,
uh,
as that part of,
of,
of the Balkans,
as you know,
path was under the Ottoman Empire.
And then,
uh,
through a whole series of,
of,
uh,
of arrangements that,
that,
uh,
of wars,
the Balkan wars before World War One,
a pass the back and forth.
Um,
and,
and essentially that,
that is one of the points of the book is that basically people,
uh,
go along very,
very well.
But that gradually what happened is that,
uh,
among competing national claims that part of Macedonia became seen by Greeks as
part of greater Greece.
Now,
whenever you heard the term greater Greece or Greater Serbia or greater Germany
or greater anything a lookout because what that means is that in the imaginary
of,
uh,
in,
in the view of,
of nationalists,
particularly aggressive nationalists,
uh,
that parts of,
of,
um,
that territories that have large percentages of a certain ethnic group or even
in some cases only minorities,
but in other cases majority's should it be included,
uh,
Numat come,
what may I in,
uh,
in,
in the,
the greater state of that particular ethnic group.
If you take the example of volt and Kosovo has about a 85% of the population,
uh,
are,
is made up of,
of,
of Muslims,
of Albanian Muslims.
And of course,
Kosovo,
uh,
his,
his was part of Serbia.
And when,
when,
when Maclossa Vich,
uh,
was talking about Greater Serbia,
Greater Serbia for him could not exist unless this Kosovo with his 85% of people
who weren't served was included in that.
Well,
anyway,
that's another story.
Um,
but what happened with this particular book is that when this book was in
manuscript arguing that,
that basically the idea that Macedonia was Greek was a construction,
was an invention and invented identity by Greek nationalists.
Uh,
the press,
the university press,
I guess I shouldn't say since this is being recorded,
I shouldn't say which one that was,
um,
chicken down and decided not to publish the book.
Uh,
they at one point got a bomb threat saying that,
that from Greek nationalists a thing that I,
if you publish this book,
uh,
we will blow up your offices in Europe.
Bam.
So,
uh,
they,
they chickened out a and quite,
you know,
in a,
in a example of just utter,
you know,
cowardice refused to publish the book.
And so they sent this author am,
I don't know,
I've read the book.
It's a really terrific book.
I,
and said,
you know,
sorry,
uh,
we're not going to publish your book too bad contract or no contract.
So University of Chicago Press published the book and uh,
uh,
when the book came out,
this particular author,
uh,
received a lot of hate mail and she received a picture of herself with a picture
of,
uh,
of a Greek flag stuck through where her heart would be.
So these are fairly serious threats.
So the point of that is not to jump on Greek nationalists,
uh,
or unserved a nationalist.
So that is certainly the Serbian nationalists.
Ultra nationalists have done just an incredible amount of damage in the,
uh,
in the Balkans and over the past,
the past decades,
but merely to underlying the point that,
that national identities are constructed.
And one of the most useful,
they're invented there are in way imaginary.
Uh,
and one of the most interesting sort of historical things you can do as an
historian is to try to figure out what from where do these,
these,
these identities come.
Now,
language pay plays a lot of it.
Maybe if I have time,
I'll,
cause I've got to do a lot today,
but this is more of a conversation than a lecture.
If I have time,
I might talk a little bit about about language,
the in the case of France,
but he'd doing feel like most people talking about nationalism.
I'm drawing on some of the thinking of Benedict Anderson and his concept of
that,
uh,
nationalism in the construction of,
of national [inaudible] identity.
I represents imagine communities because basically if you,
uh,
if you consider yourself a member of x nationality,
you are,
uh,
you are creating links or you're agreeing to links with people whom you don't
know.
People that live in Portland,
Oregon or people that live in Albuquerque,
New Mexico or people that live in New Jersey,
even though we are sitting here in Connecticut.
Um,
and so one of,
uh,
one of the useful aspects of,
of Anderson's a account is,
is yet again to,
uh,
looking back at the construction of nationalism,
to see that,
that here we have that old story that it states and large scale economic change
that are the two driving forces,
uh,
in the construction of national identities.
Now I've gone on,
you know,
at least in two lectures and part of another one talking about British a
national identity.
And I'm certainly not going to go through that again except to say that,
uh,
that it was for cautiously early the sense of being British.
Uh,
and I also argued along the line that that we can now at least for elites say
that French national identity began to be a constructed,
uh,
in,
at least by the middle of,
of the 18th century.
But if,
when you think of the real hot spots,
the real trouble spots of,
um,
of,
of the 20th century,
uh,
when you think of the origins of World War One,
which we will be doing,
thinking out loud together,
uh,
it,
over the next couple of weeks,
uh,
we will be considering,
eastern Europe,
central Europe and the Balkans.
And what's important to understand,
and here this is a reasonably decent transition from the initial discussion of
this anthropologist excellent book,
uh,
is that in most of those places,
there was no sense of national identity of being Slovene,
of being check,
of being Croat,
uh,
of being Bulgarian,
of being Ukrainian or Ruthenian.
The two two are essentially the same,
uh,
until quite late in the 19th century.
And so part of what's going on in Europe,
uh,
between let's say 1880s and 1914 is this an incredible advancement in quotes,
if you want to call it that,
uh,
in thinking with the emergence of,
of a national identity of ethnic national identity,
uh,
in that identities competing and demanding their own states in that part of the
world.
And of course,
when,
uh,
in late June,
1914,
a 16 year old,
heavily armed guy,
Serb nationalist,
uh,
I went to put my feet in the,
in the,
which my feet still exist,
but the places that the steps in Syria,
they will no longer exist because of,
of a,
of all the bombing and the place where Princip shot arts.
Fran for a Francis Ferdinand.
Uh,
the assassination that led to,
uh,
because of this,
the,
the sort of,
uh,
entangling alliances,
a diplomatic alliances that led to World War One,
um,
uh,
that,
that he was someone who practically could not have existed,
uh,
in the middle of the 19th century,
even though among Serb elites there,
there was,
uh,
there was a national,
a sense,
and I'm going to give you some examples taking out of,
taken from Anderson,
uh,
of even,
the publication and the very first dictionaries in languages,
uh,
that we now in our f are quite common for us to,
to,
uh,
to identify with national states,
with ethnic national states.
Uh,
but in fact that the,
the,
some of these states as some of these languages did not even have their own
written dictionaries until the middle of the 19th century.
And that's not so long ago.
So nationalism has to be constructed,
uh,
a sense of self identity has to be constructed.
And so that's Kinda what I want.
Uh,
I talk about now,
let me say something.
And if the beginning is that because of the French revolution and because of the
development in,
in Europe and in other places of parliamentary regimes and democracies,
uh,
it's fairly common to think,
well,
um,
national selfconsciousness equals and desire for national states.
And you can't have that with,
uh,
with a monarchy.
Well,
that's not really true at all.
I mean,
that's influenced,
for example,
by the experience of the United States.
Now the United States,
the 13 colonies,
English was,
was overwhelmingly,
uh,
the language of the 13 colonies.
And they are rebelling,
uh,
at the,
you know,
in 1776 in all of that against other English speaking people,
uh,
who happened to had a,
a monarchy.
And so no tannic,
no taxation without representation really became also a kind of an anti,
uh,
Marnika monarchists,
a sentiment.
Uh,
if you think of the Spanish,
uh,
or the rebellions in Latin America against Spain,
there to,
uh,
the rebellion,
though there were,
you know,
millions of people,
uh,
who have indigenous peoples who,
who,
who did not speak Spanish.
But basically it was a,
it was a rebellion of,
of,
of Spanish speakers against a monarch.
Uh,
that was Spanish speaking,
uh,
in the case of Spain.
But if you think about really extreme ethnic nationalism,
uh,
at the end of the 19th century,
you think of two states who help kind of push the world to the catastrophe.
That was World War One.
Uh,
uh,
one has to,
to,
uh,
point the finger at a both Russia,
and uh,
and Germany,
uh,
which had autocracies.
Uh,
and that the campaign,
for example,
this is jumping ahead a little bit,
but just,
I'm providing you an overview of the campaign of,
of Russification,
uh,
that was undertaken by the Russians Czars uh,
a brutal campaign against non Russian minorities,
uh,
was in part a response to rebellions within the Russian empire by polls,
for example,
who rise up in 1831 and an 1863.
And our crushed like grapes,
uh,
at an 1863 Bismarck,
the chancellor of Germany congratulates the czar for,
for stopping on,
on the Polish and surgeons.
But the campaign and Russia furcation,
uh,
um,
was part of,
of the reinvention of Russian national identity.
And I talk my talk about Peter the Great,
I talked about how he was,
you know,
so I'm selfish.
That's great.
Russian patriot,
well,
uh,
they,
the Russian,
uh,
aggressive Russian nationalism pixus targets a rather systematically and
campaigns of Russian Russification and the big pogrom,
the massacre occurs of Jews in Adesa,
uh,
you know,
in Crimea,
uh,
and in other places or cheered on by the Russian czar,
by Nicholas the second who am,
I will talk about when I,
when I get to,
uh,
other Russian revolution who saw this is a healthy thing,
that the Jews are being beaten to death by real Russians.
Uh,
and this was part of,
of his,
uh,
his campaign of Russia furcation.
Uh,
in the case of Germany,
you've got this sort of,
you know,
mad cap,
uh,
um,
loser,
uh,
Bill Helm,
the second,
uh,
you know,
cracking bottles of champagne or not a champagne,
but of reasoning,
as I said,
over,
over big,
speedy battleships,
powerful battleships and all of that.
And so nobody was more nationalist,
uh,
aggressive nationalists.
Then bill helm,
the second,
the Kaiser who kept saying whether disingenuously that he was the number one
German,
uh,
and all of that.
So we can get rid of the idea that,
that,
uh,
that strong national identity,
necessarily has a parliamentary,
uh,
outcome.
I mean,
the case of Britain,
well,
we're not going to,
I've talked about written too much,
but I,
the case of Britain is pretty interesting too,
but there you have a,
a monarch without real power,
but Victoria Rep represents in the imaginary of the British citizens,
uh,
what,
you know,
the stability and the really the constitutional settlement of,
of the British empire.
But yet,
uh,
a couple of points,
you know,
it need to be made is that that,
um,
language,
uh,
is important in all of this.
And,
and,
uh,
um,
though not always,
I mean me,
if I have time,
I'll give a Swiss example,
uh,
later on.
Uh,
but basically,
uh,
in the case of Russian and German nationalism and French nationalism and even
Spanish nationalism,
uh,
because of the dominance of Castillo,
one looks back to the time when national languages,
uh,
are,
which are already existed,
are used and become identified with this self identity of national people.
Now,
Latin was the language.
I mean,
Latin was the language of,
of,
uh,
um,
of,
of science,
of diplomacy,
of everything.
Uh,
and it really part of it that what's intriguing about the,
uh,
about the scientific revolution is that an important about it is that,
that,
that the vernacular languages begin to,
to be used as a way of communicating a scientific discoveries.
There's a little bit in that chapter that you read about that.
Um,
and,
and certainly language is closely tied to national,
uh,
the national self identity.
Uh,
and of course,
one of the ways when a nationalism is his,
uh,
his most aggressive and most vulgar is when a very ordinary people whipped off
on by elites in some ways are urged on by elites.
Begin identifying people who don't speak the same language is somehow,
uh,
as somehow not part of this imagined community.
You know,
an obvious example would the,
uh,
you know,
all of the Hungarians who after the treaty of Versailles,
uh,
in 1919 and the subsequent treaties,
a named after a pair of suburbs,
uh,
are included in,
in Romania and are treated as,
you know,
as outsiders.
And,
and this is very important even in the origins of the,
of,
of the 1989 a revolution that brought down the dreadful to chest choose,
uh,
dictators in,
in Romania.
But anyway,
you know,
the,
the vernacular,
uh,
develops,
if you exclude,
you know,
the cases of Spain,
of Spanish,
Latin American,
rebelling against Spain and the,
and the Americans rebelling against,
against the British and the development of these,
these languages,
uh,
and the use of the languages and their identity.
With this.
Imagine community is obviously a very important,
uh,
part of,
of this as well.
And with the development of the concept of being a citizen.
And then,
you know,
this is why the friendship,
one of the many reasons the French revolution is so important,
uh,
that you're no longer the subject of the king.
You're a situa.
Yeah.
Or if you're female,
you're a situa yen.
Nah.
Uh,
uh,
citizenship,
takes on this kind of linguistic,
uh,
aspect as well.
During the French Revolution,
uh,
there was a revolutionary priests called the Abbe Greg.
Wow.
I think I mentioned him in the book and,
and he thought that the,
all of these regional languages should be a squished like grapes.
I be guess somehow they stood in the way of,
of a true French national identity.
Um,
you know,
the,
the whole language.
I mean,
it's so terribly complicated because,
uh,
in the,
in the case of Italy,
which is sort of a,
in some ways a counterexample,
um,
I think I said before,
but it's still,
it's true that,
that at the time you were Italian unification,
only about four or 5% of the population of Italy,
of the whole boot and Cecily spoke with is now considered to be Italian.
Uh,
the case of Francis is it,
which I know more about is,
is equally fascinating.
I,
because at the time of the French revolution,
half the French population did not speak French.
There was a lot of bilingualism,
uh,
but they did not speak French.
Uh,
and if you imagine a map of,
of France,
and I think I went through this very quickly before,
but if you imagine a map of France,
and if you start at the top,
uh,
they spoke,
near alone day or,
or,
or Dutch,
uh,
in Dunkirk and places like that.
And if you move over to Alsace and,
and much of the hen they spoke,
uh,
a German dialect there,
and that would be a majority language until,
well after World War One,
I mean that and that and how the French tried to get rid of the German,
uh,
is another story of sort of national aggression even in the context of Germany's
defeat after war one.
And then if you move further south as you go to [inaudible],
which was,
don't write this down,
but it's,
I've always said it was next to France in 1860 people spoke essentially
Piedmontese,
which is the language spoken in northern Italy,
uh,
in the state of the strongest date of Italy,
Piedmont,
Sardinia.
And then you go further down and they spoke what they spoke,
Provence,
Sal,
Sol as in,
you know,
Shonda fill hat and mine and mine only sauce and,
and uh,
and these,
these,
uh,
Provence,
all poets sitting up at a place called [inaudible] and freezing in the,
and the winds of the muse trial,
uh,
and reading each other,
Provence hell poetry.
Uh,
then you go to a loading dock and they spoke a [inaudible],
which is a language of,
of,
of upcoming,
that's a southern French,
uh,
language.
Uh,
uh,
it's a written language.
Uh,
you go to Catalonia and they spoke caterpillar,
no surprise there.
I,
you go into the boss' country and they spoke boss,
which is only a remotely connected to,
to finish and Magyar that has,
those are the three hardest languages in Europe.
I mean,
how they got there.
That's another whole story.
You know,
we don't really know if you go north.
They spoke Gus,
uh,
if you go into Brittany,
they spoke a Brett tone,
which has nothing to do with French at all of what tall.
Uh,
and then,
but even in places that didn't have languages,
uh,
there were Patois and a,
Patois is a sort of denigrating term.
This is what they speak,
Patois and others,
they don't speak really French,
but in central France,
or they spoke one pot,
Twi and the Limu Zam,
they spoke another Patois that was related to that one.
Uh,
even in the lower valley,
people spoke Patois.
So this did not condemn them to eternal backwardness.
Uh,
and one might say that that in,
in the construction of French national identity that,
um,
you know,
there was an argument a long time ago by my late friend Eugen Weber that said
that all French national identity had to be constructed between 1880 and 1910
because of railroads,
military conscription and education,
railroads,
military conscription and education.
It's easy to see how that would work.
Uh,
but in fact,
I mean,
he missed a,
one of the complexity of this,
uh,
a glorious country is that you,
you know,
that lots of Breton soldiers,
uh,
didn't learn a French until they were in the trenches if they're lucky enough to
survive and world war one.
And they still spoke breath tall in,
uh,
in,
in the 18,
uh,
in the,
in the 1920s,
in 1930s.
And they're still old ladies in,
in Brittany that still speak,
but tall.
And their command of French is,
is,
uh,
a bit,
problematic or in Corsica.
They're still have many people to speak course Corsicans.
They may or may not feel like they're French.
Uh,
uh,
so it,
it's in bilingualism.
I mean,
I'll just as a little aside in the village where,
you know,
I spent half my life actually in the last,
almost in the last,
uh,
25 years or so.
Uh,
people spoke Patois and not French through the 1930s.
and then that really sort of disappeared.
And now older friends of ours,
uh,
understand Patois,
but they don't speak it.
And I had something from a book for a,
I did and I needed someone,
I needed someone to look at to make sure that what had written in Patois was
correct.
Not that I wrote it,
but,
or I took from something and he and my friend,
my bull partner,
Lou,
he,
his parents spoke that as their main language,
but he,
he couldn't correct it.
He cause he,
it's just those languages are disappearing.
It,
uh,
but,
the,
the point of all this is,
is that,
uh,
now the more we know about national self identity,
it's possible to have more than one identity.
Uh,
and it's also just a leap of faith to say,
oh,
well,
so and so who are you?
You ask who they are and that they're going to say,
well,
I'm German,
or I'm friends.
It's going to be the first thing that they're going to say.
They may say,
I'm from this village where I'm from,
this family where I'm from,
this region,
uh,
or I'm Catholic or Protestant or Jewish or,
or,
or Muslim,
uh,
some,
response like that.
But yet when we think of these,
of nationalism,
we think of these languages as being motors for elites first and then ordinary
people to demand states that the borders of states be drawn in a way that
reflects their ethnicity.
And after World War One and the treaty of Versailles,
you know,
you'd gone to war over the whole damn question of nationalism.
You know,
all these millions of people get killed,
dying and terrible ways,
you know,
gas and,
and everything else.
A flame throwers and machine guns and all this stuff that we'll,
we'll,
we'll talk about.
And so they say,
well,
Geez,
you know,
if we draw the lines around these peoples and give everybody a state,
that'll be cool.
And then we won't have wars anymore.
So they get all these big maps and these map makers and they tried to draw these
state boundaries of the after the collapse of the four empires.
And it doesn't work.
You can't do it.
And then you've got winners and losers.
And so if you get to punish the losers like hungry,
then you leave Hungary,
this sort of small country,
uh,
with much of its population living on the other side of borders.
And either imagining that that should still be part of Hungary or wanting
themselves to live back in Hungary where there'd be nothing for them at all.
But yet the period we're talking about and the period that I began with,
you've got these kind of,
this mobilization of elite saying,
holy cow,
we need our own state.
And Remember Elian,
I already gave you a lecture to go all these checks sitting in 1848 in a room
like this and not quite as nice.
And they say,
Jesus,
if the ceiling falls in,
that's the end of the Czech national movement.
Uh,
but,
but between 1848,
the springtime of the peoples in 1914,
you have millions of people who,
a couple of decades before that had absolutely no sense of being Slovene or,
or very little sense of being Slovene or Slovak or,
uh,
you know,
Crider or whatever,
who are suddenly,
you know,
making national demands and,
and,
and wanting to have a separate state within the context,
for example,
of,
or to be independent from the WHO Garren Empire.
And one of those people was the 16 year old boy,
uh,
Princip who blows the brains out of Franz Joseph out of,
out of Franz Ferdinand and his wife.
I,
when this car backs up the,
the wrong street in Sarajevo,
though there were some of his friends were out there trying to get them to.
So that's just a way of kind of thinking,
uh,
thinking,
about,
uh,
about that,
that stuff now.
Um,
okay.
let me give you a couple of examples here.
I wrote down,
um,
Ukraine,
Ukraine is a huge country,
huge,
uh,
important country a and test a relationship with Russia now because of,
of,
uh,
having got Crimea and Russia,
wants to do,
to have Crimea and,
and all of this highly contested relationship because of the number of Russians,
uh,
who live in,
in Ukraine and,
and all of that.
And for Ukrainians,
uh,
the sense that Ukraine always exists,
existed,
uh,
is always taken as a given.
The first Ukrainian grammar book,
and this is not dissing Ukrainians or anybody,
but I'm just staying there.
The reality is that the first Ukrainian grammar book with published,
not in 1311,
uh,
or in 1511,
but in 18,
19 is the very first one,
the first check German dictionary.
You know,
if you're going to have a national identity,
you got to have a dictionary so you can translate things between German and
Czech is published.
Uh,
it's a long publication process.
1935 to 1939 a to z,
the first check national organization and the one I just described,
uh,
starts in 1846.
Now,
that's pretty recent.
Uh,
the first Norwegian grammar book,
which is distinguished Norwegian as a separate language and a separate,
a separate identity from say,
Swedish and Danish is not till 1848,
uh,
grammar book.
And the first a dictionary that is separating,
uh,
making a distinction between Norwegian and Danish isn't until 1850.
And that's what I mean about,
uh,
you know,
about the construction of national identity is that,
you have to have,
uh,
you know,
that you have to have a sense that,
that you are part of this imagine community.
Now,
let me,
having said that before,
I talk about a counterexample yes,
yes,
yes.
Let me do this like that.
Why not?
Um,
let me,
um,
let me give you a couple examples that,
that I hope make the point.
And these are,
I'm drawing from,
from uh,
uh,
from Snyder,
um,
that,
let's look at why at the end of the 19th century,
Lithuanian nationalism develops Lithuania,
Lithuania,
capitol,
Vilnius,
big tall basketball players like a sub.
Oh,
nice.
Uh,
who played in the NBA.
Um,
you know,
that,
why Lithuanian nationalism rapidly develops,
but only at the end of the 19th century.
And Belorussian nationalism doesn't develop at all until way in,
uh,
well it's even pushing it to say in the twenties and thirties.
Now there's this huge Byelorussia or was it,
you know,
in polar and the various times I go to Poland,
there were,
uh,
I was there,
there was a huge dinner with all these Belorussians,
uh,
who are,
most of them were dissidents and are there to discuss the history of,
of Belorussia,
but not none of them.
What we're going to be claiming that bellow Russia and has had an identity.
He had a self identity,
uh,
before,
of the 1930s but listen,
we existed,
uh,
Lithuania was part of the Polish Lithuanian Commonwealth.
So,
which exists basically until the last partition in Poland in 1795 when Pola and
gets munched bouffy by,
you know,
by the great powers.
Um,
but,
but so who do these people think they were?
Well,
they think they're Polish.
Uh,
they considered themselves Polish and Paul's already had a basis for
nationalism.
They had a written language.
They have heroes,
Chopin,
there's one,
Chopin didn't go to Paris by the waiter,
you know,
as a refugee from a Russian repression and went there to further his musical
career.
But anyway,
uh,
he wrote,
there were lots that had to do with oppression,
with a Polish,
uh,
national themes,
folklore,
uh,
and all of that.
Um,
and so,
uh,
there,
there were Duke's,
there had been dukes of Lithuania grand,
Duke's,
uh,
but they never published.
They didn't accept Lithuanian a as a language.
Um,
and if they wanted to get anywhere,
they tried to pass themselves off as polls.
Pilsudski a name you'll come back to who destroyed the Polish republic as one
after another of European states goes a authoritarian and the 1920s and thirties
peeled Zeus key,
who was the hero of the miracle,
the Vistula river.
When the Polish army turns back the Red Army,
uh,
you know,
at the end of World War One and just sort of amazing,
moment pilled Zoosk he himself,
you know,
was the son considered himself?
Uh,
uh,
considering selfless.
He was Lithuanian.
Uh,
but he considered himself Polish.
He was absolutely a Lithuanian,
but yet there was a Lithuanian language,
but it was not spoken by the elites.
So who spoke the Lithuanian language?
It was spoken by the peasants.
So at the end of the 19th century,
you suddenly got all these intellectuals,
these Lithuanian intellectuals and grand Duke's and priests and various people
saying,
wait a minute,
we are Lithuanians.
And happily the Lithuanian peasantry has saved our language from the last
Lithuanian Duke who spoke Lithuanian died before Columbus discovered America.
Tim Snyder inform me.
So suddenly they say,
oh,
baby,
these Lithuanian peasants,
instead of just being,
we won't treat them anymore as the scum of the earth.
They have preserved our language for us.
And suddenly you have poets writing and Lithuanian and it's no longer a disgrace
to be seen,
uh,
as,
a Lithuanian.
Uh,
there was,
uh,
one of these poets,
a guy called,
uh,
Rica,
who died in 1899.
He recalled when he was in school as the Lithuanian kid is smart Lithuanian kid.
He says,
my self preservation instinct told me not to speak and Lithuanian and to make
sure that no one noticed that my father wore a rough peasants coat and could
only speak Lithuanian.
I did my best to speak spoke Polish,
even though I spoke at badly.
Polish it for is a terribly difficult language.
There's all these sorts of squiggly things that,
that,
uh,
you know,
that you just,
it doesn't,
things don't pronounce like it's supposed to,
but are you saying there's supposed to be,
and I don't do very well at the picking it Polish,
but,
um,
when my father and other relatives visited me,
I stayed away from them.
And when I could see that fellow students or gentlemen were watching,
he was embarrassed to be basically Lithuanian and the son of a Lithuanian
peasant.
I only spoke with them,
uh,
at ease when we were alone or outside.
I saw myself as a pole and thus has a gentleman.
I had imbibed the Polish spirit,
but it's only,
you know,
by the end of the century,
he sees himself as a Lithuanian and he is one of these people who is pushing
Lithuanian nationalism.
And it is,
uh,
it is embraced.
Now how does this physically happen?
I mean,
how do you do you don't wake up and say,
oh,
well I was Polish yesterday and,
uh,
as a subject of,
of the czar,
uh,
cause we're going to,
Poland is divided between Prussia,
Austria,
Hungary,
and Russia.
But if you were in the Russian part of what they called Congress,
Poland,
and suddenly today I'm Lithuanian.
How does that happen?
Well,
because Lithuania is next to Germany and this is also something we'll make you
again,
think of what I said about the enlightenment is that lots of literature is
smuggled in to,
uh,
into Lithuania in Lithuanian.
And so therefore,
uh,
there's this wild or profusion of Lithuanian literature that comes into,
I,
that comes into Lithuania,
uh,
which of course as you know,
was not,
was not independent.
It's part of the Russian empire.
Um,
and,
and so,
uh,
there was another reason too,
which is for the Russian imperial secret police,
the ones that they're really worried about,
they're worried about the polls because the polls after all of it risen up in
1831 and an 1863.
And so they're on the lookout for people that are there say,
hey,
I'm Polish.
We want to Polish state,
and they don't pay much attention.
They don't really care about these Lithuanians,
uh,
who are discovering their own self identity.
We're constructing their self identity.
Now why does it even happen in Belarus?
I don't have time to tell you very much about this,
but the main thing is,
is that a bell or Bruce is a long way from anywhere,
uh,
at the time or there isn't any kind of elite in Byelorussia,
that embraces Belorussian anything.
Uh,
and so the language is not seen part of a national self identity that basically,
uh,
does not exist and would not exist until at least after World War One.
Uh,
and now,
you know,
Lithuanians,
we'll look back on their country as,
as if Lithuania had always had this sort of self identity,
but,
you know,
it was part of the,
if part of the Polish Lithuanian Commonwealth and,
and a booth that was more basically a Polish operation than it was a territorial
thing,
more than any kind of,
of,
of construction of,
of two,
two people's participating in this.
Um,
this thing.
Furthermore,
um,
you know,
Belorussians Co we're,
we're not allowed to publish in,
um,
in,
in Belorussian and were Lithuanian priests began giving sermons and Lithuanian,
and you've got all this sort of,
uh,
written material coming in,
in the vernacular that nobody read Belorussian in church.
There were no priests too to say that this is,
that this is our language.
Um,
and the Byelorussians who were literate could read Polish or Russian or both.
Uh,
but,
uh,
in,
in many cases,
not what would become Belorussian,
uh,
at all.
And so by the end of the 19th century,
when you've got these other people claim insisting that were Slovenes and where
this and that,
uh,
Belorussians speakers called himself Russian,
if they were a orthodox,
they call themselves,
that is orthodox religion.
They call themself Polish if they were Roman Catholic.
And if they were simply looking out for themselves,
they just called themselves local.
They said,
we are part of,
we live in the Russian empire and that's who we are.
There was no sense of being Belorussian.
So there are different outcomes in,
in uh,
all of this stuff now.
Um,
having said that,
yeah,
yeah.
This is what I'm going to get there.
We're going to get there.
Let me give you another,
uh,
example.
I want to,
I want to find this date.
Um,
that'll make you at least re sync,
realize that you can have a national identity and have more than one,
uh,
one language.
It's very complex.
I guess the most interesting case now would be Belgium,
which I don't have a lot of time to talk about.
But in Belgium,
I have a friend who,
um,
who works in the,
in the Belgian,
uh,
Ministry of Culture,
in Brussels in about seven years ago,
I asked him,
I said,
do you think you think Belgium will,
it will exist in 10 years?
And he said,
I hope not.
This guy works for the Belgian Ministry of Culture.
And this reflects the sharp antagonism between,
uh,
between the Flemish,
who basically live in the north and east,
but above all the northern parts of,
uh,
of,
of Belgium and who are more prosperous and who are more numerous about say,
55% of the population and their tensions with the walloons that the French
speakers,
you know,
the ash and,
and [inaudible] and all those places.
Uh,
and then,
uh,
and then also in Brussels,
which is technically part of,
uh,
of,
part of the Flemish zone,
but because of the bureaucracy and because Belgium,
Brussels is the most important city has become this sort of third place,
hotly contested by the Flemish and real serious,
uh,
it attentions there.
If you ask in French,
you know,
what time the train is to,
uh,
to,
bluish,
uh,
you know,
they,
they're not going to reply and they know perfectly well,
Eh,
they just simply won't reply and pretend that you did not,
not all of them,
but there a serious tensions where component also by the fact that there tends
to be,
not everybody,
but the,
the far right is really,
uh,
is really,
really,
uh,
tied to Flemish self identity.
Uh,
and the walloons that is the French,
uh,
many of whom want to be attached to as French speakers want to be attached to
France,
uh,
see their lives.
It's very different also that,
that the,
that the Walloon part of Belgium is basically the rust belt.
Uh,
and that the Flemish part is very,
very,
uh,
a prosperous in comparison,
but yet Belgium,
which didn't exist to 1831 legally didn't exist anyway.
They,
the revolution in 1830 and 31,
it's still there by the way.
There's also 5%,
uh,
tacked on after Versailles around a town called,
you've been,
who speak German.
Uh,
but anyway,
there we go.
Uh,
but Belgium is still there and as possible,
when I say when I'm in Belgium,
which I am frequently,
I think that,
I think now this is really Europe because of the complexity of it.
And so you can have a national identity without having,
you know,
a single dominant language if the two sides are tolerant.
Well,
let me give you another quick example and then we got to rock and roll on to the
age of empires.
He wouldn't have a shortcut now,
not Austria-hungary I got to time.
So,
so a age empire.
But what about Switzerland?
Here you've got Switzerland.
What does it,
I,
if I remember correct this correctly,
the statistics,
I think the French population speaking French population is 22%.
Um,
German speaking or Swiss Deutsch,
uh,
speaking population is about,
oh,
maybe 71% or something like that.
Uh,
you've walked,
you've got a Italian speaking population of about 5%,
and you also have another language called Roman Nash,
which has spoken only by a few hundred thousand people.
And so that's,
that's a one,
two,
three languages already plus English because of the international role of Geneva
is the fourth major language,
uh,
fourth recognized language in Switzerland.
But,
you know,
Switzerland or if you think of Switzerland now is so prosperous and then it was
full of chocolate and full banks and full of watches and,
and Eh,
and,
and all of that.
And you think everybody yodeling in cows,
you know,
running around and everybody's very happy in eating perch on a lakes.
Uh,
but,
but you know,
so,
but the Swiss have to create this sort of sense that,
that they have always been a nation,
but of course they haven't.
And well,
Switzerland,
the decentralized federalist nature of,
of Switzerland was always there too during the reformation to say somebody was
turning Swiss meant that they were rejecting the demands of their lords there.
Lords and rejecting the religion imposed by their lords and turning to
Protestantism if they were in a Catholic area or to Catholicism,
if they were on a process in the area.
Uh,
and,
and the Swiss were,
were big time mercenaries,
uh,
and,
and big time farmers.
But Switzerland,
uh,
flat his last war and it,
you know,
early in the,
in the 19th century has been neutral.
Uh,
and it's very complicated story what happened in Switzerland during the war.
Two.
It's very tragic.
It's Switzerland.
The Swiss did not,
you know,
they turn so many Jews back at the frontier and send them back to it,
to the Germany and the laundering Nazi money and all that.
And,
and,
uh,
um,
you know,
I'm not dumping on,
on the Swiss,
but it's a complicated story,
uh,
in the case of,
of their neutrality.
But,
um,
so they decided in 1891 on the 600 to anniversary of what,
of the Swiss,
um,
a confederation that Switzerland began in 1291 that a bunch of people got
together with between all the cows and eating chocolate and,
and,
and all that stuff.
Um,
and that they announced that they were Switzerland.
And so,
so here's again what I mean that what Anderson means about this or imagine
community that you're inventing a kind of date that you said,
well,
we've,
we've been like that since then and that's all there is to it.
But if you've got all these different languages and the languages are not as far
apart as French and Dutch,
when in a way they are,
because Dutch is really where the Dutch would not see it that way,
but is it a German dialect?
But nonetheless,
the Swiss are a lot better at learning each other's language.
Then,
uh,
the French speakers,
certainly our learning,
learning Dutch,
which they view as impossible and don't like the key.
They don't like to have their kids having to learn it in school and all that.
It's terribly complicated,
but so they imagine this community.
Uh,
but it exists.
I mean,
especially the exist people have a sense of being Swiss despite these different
languages.
Uh,
Eh,
um,
they're not the disparities economic disparities that are there are between
urban and rural life,
but nothing like that.
The disparity between the Flemish parts of,
uh,
of,
Belgium,
and,
and the French parts of Belgium.
If you exclude Roussel Brussels,
you know that now,
but let me end in the last,
um,
five minutes and seven seconds.
That is a,
a lot of,
to me,
let me end with a counterexample,
which you can read about.
And I said at the beginning,
uh,
you inspired by the sheer horror of the Balkans and tell me you aren't old
enough to remember,
you know,
of certainly not my God.
I am,
uh,
you know,
all of this stuff that happened in the 90s,
but you are,
uh,
the late nineties.
You can probably remember all the massacres and stuff like that.
And I said at the very beginning of the hour or the beginning of the 50 minutes,
that people now tend to look longingly back and they say,
Geez,
you know,
uh Huh.
Oh,
the Austrian gear and empire at sure lasted a long time.
He had 15 major nationalities.
It was kind of a balancing act.
You've got becomes the dual monarchy in 1867 where the Hungarians have more or
less,
uh,
equal rights.
The two to,
uh,
you've got Australia and you've got a hungry,
but you got another 13 people's,
at least 13 peoples living within the empire.
You've got the Croats who have their own nobility and they're kind of given
favored status so that they can,
uh,
you know,
so this whole thing is sort of balancing like that,
but how does the place stay together?
How does Austria,
Hungary stay,
uh,
stay together?
I end and that one of those chapters,
that chapter with the,
uh,
this very famous scene from,
from uh,
uh,
from the parliament in Vienna where you've got these different ethnic groups
playing drums and singing songs and trying to disrupt the speeches by,
uh,
by people from the other nationalities.
And you've got all these problems with the South Slavs wanting,
uh,
at least minimal representation has sort of this third state in quotes between
along with Austria,
Hungary.
How does the thing stay together?
We'll basically in this way,
I'm just telling you briefly about things that you can read about,
but I just wanted to make some sense of it.
Um,
first of all,
uh,
is that the empire,
the language of the empire is German.
And to get somewhere in the Austrian hearing empire,
uh,
you need to know German.
Uh,
and so learning German becomes this kind of a social mobility.
The way that learning French becomes for somebody from gas Gascony a form of
social mobility.
You can get a job in the bureaucracy if you're going to have a huge old,
humongous empire,
uh,
you know,
going all the gall,
the weighted to the rugged terrain of Bosnia Herzegovina,
uh,
you know,
you gotta have,
you gotta have officials in their little hats since they're little desks who are
going to be running all this stuff.
And you've got to have a,
have a language.
And so the language of the empire is German.
And so,
uh,
this is not mean,
mean that people feel that they're German.
I mean,
after all being,
they're not German,
they're,
they're German speakers within the Austrian Gary and empire.
But it gives them in allegiance to this apparatus.
Secondly,
the middle class,
the middle class is German,
uh,
largely German excepted Budapest where it's,
it's Hungarian,
but,
but still many Germans live in Budapest as well.
And one of the things that I wish I had time to talk about,
but you can't talk about everything,
is that what you've got in these cities,
and I mentioned this just a reference the other day,
cities of all of eastern Europe and central Europe,
you have [inaudible] of the cities because all of the cities,
whether you're talking about Budapest or you're talking about Warsaw or you
know,
anywhere you're talking about have a,
or even Vilnius,
you have strong,
large German populations,
uh,
and also large Jewish populations.
Um,
and in the course of the last decades of the 19th century,
you have the sort of arrival of love of peasants,
a Estonian peasants into Italian of check peasants into Prague,
of Hungarian peasants,
into Budapest,
of Lithuanian peasants,
into Vilnius,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
But you've still got in the Austrian Garren,
uh,
case,
you still have,
even in Budapest,
you still have a large middle class that is fundamentally a German and believes
in the empire.
Um,
next you've got dynastic loyalty.
Ah,
you've got this,
this,
this old dude,
Franz Joseph,
uh,
who,
had,
who had been there since 1848.
You know,
he lives til 1916.
The same guy.
Uh,
and that,
that makes Victoria's seemed once you had a short rain and people are,
you know,
people have an allegiance to this dynasty.
I mean,
they have per dynasty had been,
you know,
hadn't been a dominant in the central Europe until there that can test the
Prussians and lose out,
you know,
in the,
in the war of 1866.
Uh,
so you've got this,
this Franz Joseph,
uh,
also you've got the church,
you've got the Catholic church.
Now,
there are lots of Protestants.
I,
for example,
in,
uh,
um,
in,
in the Czech lands in Bohemia,
whereas slow Slovakia is almost overwhelmingly Catholic in what would become
check Czechoslovakia and then divorce in amicably and us in,
uh,
1990,
93,
um,
and Co Croatia is,
is overwhelmingly Catholic aggressively.
So,
um,
and so despite the fact you have these huge Muslim enclaves in,
in,
in the old,
what had been the,
the,
the Ottoman Empire,
you still have this church is a unifying force,
not for everybody.
It's certainly not for the Jews,
uh,
not for the Gypsies of who are the Roma who are very many there.
And,
and not,
not for Protestants and not for Orthodox Serbs.
Uh,
which is part of the tensions there as well cause they saw a Russia as being
their protector.
Um,
you can read more about that,
but that,
that's another thing.
And finally you've got the army.
The army is a form of,
of,
of social promotion as well.
You know,
the army doesn't have the bad reputation that the French army did for,
for,
uh,
you know,
shooting down.
A young girl's protesting,
young women protesting in,
in strikes.
Uh,
it doesn't have the reputation that the brutal guard Savella did in,
in Spain.
The army is seen.
It's seen as,
as,
as a useful way of representing the empire.
Uh,
it has a good reputation and German,
the language German is,
is,
is the language of command.
And so these soldiers,
uh,
are,
and the soldiers are drawn from all of these nationalities.
Uh,
they at least have that in common.
and,
um,
so most of them to,
to conclude the most important question to ask about this empire,
particularly in reference to what I've been saying about this whole hour is,
is to not look at,
you know,
why it came apart,
but to look at how it held together so long and given the horrors perpetuated on
Europe by nationalism,
uh,
from then and even before,
as during the French revolution to this very day sometimes.
And I never thought I'd ever say this about me,
uh,
looking nostalgically back to an empire.
Uh,
but it is an interesting and at least food for thought.
So on that note,
Bonepar t and to see you on Wednesday.